podcaster and UFC commentator Joe Rogan
on Whose program I've appeared twice is
opening an anti-cancel culture comedy
club called comedy Mothership in Austin
Texas and it will feature comedians who
have been quote canceled this might be
news to you such as David Lucas Ron
White Tim Dillon Tony Hinchcliffe and
Roseanne Barr Rogan says that he wants
to create a safe space for comedians to
share dark humor without fear of being
canceled do comedians get canceled for
their humor or are there sometimes
repercussions to things they say that
aren't part of their acts which some
people find offensive or disgusting and
others might choose not to go to their
shows is it really true that these are
even cancellations let me know in the
comments